[Musique]
coc
cette journée d'inauguration est
particulièrement importante puisque lé
couple est en fait au colloque à limbe
russie qui est donc un colloque qui vise
à permettre aux étudiants de l3 et de m1
de s'orienter ensuite dans la suite de
leurs études en master 2 et en doctorat
donc c'est une
j'aurais très importante pour la
physique également donc au titre du
terme de l'inauguration du bâtiment
puisque ce bâtiment est l'aboutissement
d'un projet qui a éclos il ya à peu près
une dizaine d'années l'idée étant en
fait deux
rapprocher tous les enseignements à
laurent donc de la fin la licence au
master en un lieu unique
sur le campus or c'est saclay ce qui
permet donc de faire converger toutes
ces différentes filières d'enseignement
de physique qui sont extrêmement large
alors c'est dans ce lieu dédié il
dispose donc de plusieurs salles de td
plusieurs dizaines de salles de travaux
pratiques avec des équipements dédiés et
également des plateformes expérimentales
dans lesquelles sont présents des
équipements qui viennent de matériel de
recherches qui vont est donc destiné à
la formation des étudiants est également
une coupole d'observation astronomique
donc la vocation de ce bâtiment est de
réunir en un lieu unique l'enseignement
dans les diverses matières
enseigner donc alors c'est et de
permettre également aux étudiants et
bien de faciliter leur interaction avec
les différents laboratoires qui sont
présents notamment à proximité de ce
bâtiment sur le plateau est également un
peu plus loin soit dans la vallée soit
un peu plus loin sur le plateau
notamment des laboratoires de
l'université du cnrs et du ceva
[Musique]
objectivement il a été conçu pour tenir
sa place sur l'ajustement la place du
lieu de vie donc il a fière une stature
sur la place du lieu de vie c'est le
fond de cette place mais si la vienne sa
stature aussi il ne pèse pas trop
négligé des hanches ils laissent passer
la lumière et il va permettre parce
déhanchements de laisser percevoir la
ligne d très belles lignes d arbres de
la forêt qui fait que la nature fait de
l'architecturé l'architecturé vient
aider à constituer la ville qui est très
proche de cette nature qui s'opposent à
cette nature
[Musique]